نشير الى الخبر العاجل الذي ورد قبل قليل
شرطه مدينه الويفيل بولايه كنتاكي افادت
بوقوع ضحايا جراء اطلاق نار بوسط المدينه
تحدثت وسائل اعلام امريكيه عن سته جرحى
على الاقل من بينهم شرطي الشرطه ايضا حتى
سكان المدينه على الابتعاد عن منطقه
الحادث ومن جهته قال مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه انه استجاب لحادثه اطلاق نار
وقعت في تلك المنطقه جنوبي الولايات
المتحده نوافيكم بالمزيد من المعلومات
حاله ورودها
وهذه المشاهدين صور مباشره لمكان وقوع
اطلاق النار طبعا المعلومات الاوليه كما
ذكرنا قبل قليل تتحدث عن سته جرحى ليس
لدينا تفاصيل حول من وراء هذا الهجوم ان
كان قد تم تحيده في تحديدا هو في وسط تلك
المدينه ولكن ليس لدينا اي معلومات حتى
الان عن المنطقه ما الذي تمثله ولكن فيما
يبدو من خلال الصور التي نشاهدها هناك صور
سيارات طبعا الشرطه قامت بتطويق المنطقه
كما نلاحظ هناك تواجد امني مكثف
والمعلومات كما تحدثنا تشير الى اطلاق نار
وسته جرحى حتى هذه اللحظه الولايات
المتحده
هذه لا تعتبر حادثه فريده من نوعها اذا
نصح التعبير في الولايات المتحده اكثر من
حوادث في اطلاق النار في اكثر من منطقه
من ولايه تحدث بين الفتره والاخرى لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات